elon musk arrives in new york city with
family brainstorms
snl ideas with paps with people out
there this is a tmz story
lama still doesn't seem to know what the
heck is in store for his big debut on
saturday night live and it's even
escorted
resorted to asking uh photo uh what do
you call it
uh paparazzi folks about what skits he
should do
the tesla ceo was in new york city
tuesday days ahead of the taking the
stage at nbc studios where he'll be
hosting snl
and the moment he showed his face in the
streets he was swarmed mostly by
autograph seekers who shoves dozens of
sharpies and
photos in his face the one thing on
everyone's mind is what he's got in
store for saturday's show
he regurgitated some ideas he was
spitballing on twitter over the weekend
including baby shark and shark tank
merging
to form baby shark tank doesn't seem
like he's touched base with
snl staff quite yet what do you think is
gonna happen
so i don't i don't think we've ever seen
anyone like elon musk
okay so traditionally who were the we
talked about
uh the bezos of the world we talked
about gates we talked about buffett
last we've never seen a
multi-multi-billionaire with such a big
personality
and a weird personality all right this
guy's clearly banging aliens or has
fascinations about that
all good but someone with this much
money
this much power danielle we can go there
you should
pull up a picture of his girlfriend kai
just so danielle understands what we're
working with here stay on snl
okay we'll stand outside now so
you had a bet with kai there's a
position a couple a couple months ago
now pull up the more recent picture you
had a bet with kai a couple months ago
who would be a bigger draw on the joe
rogan podcast
you went with yes exactly danielle now
you're on my team
um kanye west or kanye west or elon musk
wasn't even close i won that ten bucks
before the show even started kai you
still got that time
nine
don't do that again he's a big boy he
could take it i thought it was finland
this guy's got a
what's the difference this is going to
be our ratings bonanza on snl i think
it's going to be way bigger than
anymore so many norwegians it's going to
be awesome we'll hear from the principal
of that norway school that
listens to podcasts keep going i think
this is going to be the biggest snl
episode ever potentially ever ever um
because he has a
a bigger than chappelle bigger than
murphy yeah bigger than trump yeah
bigger than any of these guys yes
john belushi back from dead i think it's
going to be i think it's going to be the
talk of the town on sunday who's john
belushi and i think it's going to be one
of those like our listeners
i think it's going to be a car wreck
situation where i don't think he's
actually that funny i think he's like
he's got childish humor
my hope is that he can actually make fun
of himself
like it it'll go very well if he can
embrace
making fun of himself maybe he can call
it the white house i mean if worse comes
to worse they can just hook him up to a
teleprompter right
okay there it is yeah i if he like makes
it
somewhere but
i think it's gonna be a ratings bonanza
i think it's gonna what do you guys
think what do you guys think
what do you think about it i think it's
gonna be a letdown or you think it's
gonna be
you know how you go to a movie like oh
my gosh i can't wait to watch
transformers three and you're like yeah
like dude where the hell is shia labeouf
and uh the
fox what's the the the other girl from
uh uh megan fox megan fox what did
i need shia labeouf to be back in there
you need kind of like a let down do you
think it's gonna be a letdown you think
is gonna come up and show up
yes i do on a one to ten i think it's
gonna be a two or a three and it's gonna
be like the remake of wall street where
oliver stone just
peed in the bed how about yourself
i mean i think i don't think it's gonna
be entertaining as much as as it's going
to be
intriguing yeah curiosity yeah people
are people can
just they're just going to want to know
you think it's going to be like a car
wreck like everyone wants to see what's
going on but it's not going to be
but it doesn't work i mean for people
who worship him and i mean he is
probably one of the most
worshiped people on the planet
everything he says is i mean hero
worship
he's talking up a joke yeah well that's
why i think dogecoin is the bubble of
all bubbles i think it's a complete joke
it started off as a joke it still is a
joke but just yeah people are
you're just upset that it's a dog not
cats so get off it well played
well played what do you think about elon
musk on snl what do you think is going
to happen
i think it's going to be very
interesting i think he is a
unpredictable guy and the world loves
unpredictable
characters an unpredictable character
can come up and say anything
he's going to push buttons the question
is going to be who's he going to
challenge when
the movie the what's the recent movie
that came out is it godzilla in uh
he tweeted about it he says i love this
movie there was a subtle shout out to
conspiracy theorists a shout out to
podcasters a shout out to this
he likes that so i think he's probably
gonna do something with conspiracy
theorists i think he's probably gonna do
something with the number 420 69 doge
uh bitcoin i think he's going to
probably touch something to do with jeff
bezos i think he's going to take a shot
at him
i think he's probably going to take some
kind of a shot at possibly newsom
california i don't know i think i think
you don't know what direction he's going
to go but
a lot of people right now are sitting
there saying they should have them do
this doesn't come up
they should have him do a skit as an
amazon driver
that's going to be amazing that'd be
hilarious this is
the kind of stuff he needs to do make
fun of himself make fun of others
this is a legacy type who would you
rather have on snl hey more bezos
not even a question not even a question
oh gosh it's not even a question right i
think bezos
although i'd like to see him and bezos
and amazon delivery van do like carpool
karaoke that'd be great
and i'd like to see noam chonsky and
tonight great that's what i'd like to
see
i'd like to see that more than i'd like
to see the other one okay all right if
we cover that
are you going to tune in live this what
what is it
saturday night saturday night you're
going to be in miami you may be tuning
in in miami
maybe okay where am i whether without
the cats
saturday night i'm still at least sunday
yeah sunday night i'm gonna tune in
i'm gonna go to tuesday to see tom you
tuning in
nope bedtime what time is bedtime
it's not bedtime i think it's kim's
birthday no it's mother's day
no that's that's that's that's right
that's the following no no no we're
doing we got some
very big business things happening in
one of the other companies and so
saturday is mother's day so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye